[Music]
all right i think we found one this is
adam lee he's the chairman of lee auto
malls which owns 16 dealerships in maine
that's used
used
used used he's looking for a new car on
their toyota lot i don't know that we're
gonna find a new car but we'll
let's keep walking for a minute this is
an experience recent car shoppers are
likely familiar with pandemic related
supply chain issues have pushed new
vehicle inventory to historic lows
prompting higher prices and months long
waits for new cars people want to buy
more cars than we have than we can
possibly produce
this is not something that's happened in
the industry
in decades the disruption coupled with a
shift toward electric vehicles is now
causing consumers and automakers to
rethink how americans buy cars
so let's take a walk around a dealership
and through an ev showroom to see how
the car purchasing process has changed
and what it might look like in the
future
buying a car has typically started here
at the dealership but these days there's
not much to see
if you'd come here a couple years ago
you just would have seen row after row
probably 10 to 15 rows of new inventory
in some use but
now what you got is a whole bunch of
empty lot nationally there were about
1.1 million new vehicles available at
the end of may that's less than a third
of what it was pre-pandemic and
inventory at lee's dealerships is the
lowest it's ever been i found one i
found the one car we have the one new
car
so rather than searching the lot many
shoppers now search the internet we are
seeing an increasing level of pre-car
buying activities happening online
whether that's researching what kind of
vehicle you need whether that's reaching
out to the dealership and increasingly
being able to see what inventory the
dealership has at lease dealerships
sales representatives field these online
inquiries helping shoppers find cars and
warning them about which vehicles may
not be in stock for weeks even months to
come
in some cases we have a one-year waiting
list and so we sort of try to encourage
them if they're looking at a vehicle
that's going to take a year to arrive
to to look at alternatives and you know
a lot of times people they know what
they want they'll wait waiting means
getting in line and getting in line
means putting down a refundable deposit
jim how are you at lee's toyota
dealership around 300 deposits are still
awaiting cars on the one hand it's nice
to have 300 sold orders in the bank when
the cars come in they go out on the
other hand in the old days those cars
would have already been sitting on the
lot and we would have delivered them
already but everyone seems to have
adapted pretty well analysts say leaner
inventory has actually benefited many
dealers as the expense to carry a
vehicle on the lot is greatly reduced
the last time you keep a vehicle on your
dealership lot and the faster that you
can sell it it is going to be a more
profitable sale overall sales volume at
lees dealerships are down roughly 10 to
15 percent from pre-pandemic levels but
he says the business like many other
dealerships is still quite profitable
a big reason the cost of cars i happen
to have the
msrp sticker to the one new car we have
in the lot that price lee is showing is
the manufacturer's suggested retail
price or msrp suggested is the key word
here because dealers are the ones who
ultimately price the vehicle so this car
is
45 109. typically buyers would negotiate
that price they see in the window down
even further but now i don't think
there's an awful lot of negotiating
going on on the price of the new car at
least not at our stores
with few cars in high demand shoppers
don't have much power to negotiate but
dealers and analysts say negotiations
were trending out even before the
pandemic price negotiation is a scenario
that consumers love to hate
hate to love
you know they want to be able to feel
like they've gotten a bit of a deal on
something but they don't like the
process of it even without negotiation
though shoppers could typically expect
to pay less thanks to deals and rebates
that push prices below msrp but
incentive levels on new vehicles hit
historic lows in may averaging 2.5 of
the average transaction price right now
dealers don't have to offer them when
they're going to have to offer
incentives and when this negotiation
sort of starts to resume will depend on
inventory coming back and that could
take more than a year analysts say
meaning prices are likely to remain high
so far this year average prices have
been over msrp each month in may buyers
paid an average of about nine hundred
dollars over sticker for in-demand
models markups can be in the thousands
we have always chosen not to mark up a
hot vehicle just that we feel the
sticker prices
it's reasonable three years ago we would
have been thrilled if you said you're
going to sell every car at msrp would
have said that's great manufacturers
have warned dealers against markups
saying they hurt the brand's image with
consumers but again dealers set the
price
at least for legacy automakers
startup electric vehicle companies like
lucid motors take a different approach
selling their cars primarily online
directly to consumers oftentimes they
know what they want and in that case
having a digital experience that is
directly connected to the company that's
that's producing the vehicles just
simplifies it there is an offline
component here lucid like tesla and
rivien have showrooms where customers
can browse sit in and customize a car in
vr before they decide to buy
but when they do the price is the price
no negotiation no incentives
i think it allows both sides both lucid
and the customer to really focus on
learning and experience rather than you
know this confrontational negotiation
that typically takes place but selling
from a studio like this isn't legal
everywhere state franchise laws require
vehicles in most places to be priced and
sold by a dealer ideally there just
there wouldn't be any laws that that say
that the manufacturer of products can't
sell them directly to their customers so
yeah we're actively working to to find
ways to overturn those those rules
while it's only evmakers using the
direct sales model now legacy automakers
are eyeing a similar approach as they
shift electric
ford in particular plans to release new
rules for how it sells its evs in
september ceo jim farley spoke last
month about keeping zero inventory at
dealers and sales being 100 online i
think our dealers can do it but the
standards are going to be brutal
they're going to be very different than
today some dealers are concerned this
may be an attempt to cut them out farley
recently met with around 300 dealers to
discuss concerns about evie sales he
emphasized that dealers are key to
ford's success
lee who doesn't sell fords sees a hybrid
model maybe you order it online from the
manufacturer but i believe it's gonna
for most it will go to the dealership
and they'll deliver the car to you this
possible shift in approach toward ev
sales comes as manufacturers and dealers
alike are learning from the changes over
the last two years there were seeds for
potential for the for exchanges in in a
process that wasn't always comfortable
for consumers and those seeds were there
and they were being explored and they've
been accelerated by a number of things
by tesla by challengers and certainly by
macro and external events question is
what's here to stay analysts and dealers
expect more online activities and less
negotiation in the future but say
incentives will return as inventory does
even if it doesn't go back to where it
was
i think lower inventory levels
may stick i hope they do it would be
better if we had 100 new cars sitting
here not 300 we just we don't need that
many still it's not an empty lot or even
a full one that worries lee instead he's
concerned about rising interest rates
and a possible recession
i think some of these changes might help
dealers whether the next recession but
in the end if people aren't buying cars
you're not making money
[Music]